it's an issue brought to our attention
by many of you our viewers having to
wait long times for an rtc bus eight
news now reporter sally jaramillo spoke
to rotc along with some drivers about it
sally i see a lot of these passengers
outside of grocery stores and stuff
waiting i mean typically how long are
these folks waiting for a bus
denise those who take the bus tell me
they have waited anywhere from 20
minutes to about an hour all of this due
to a shortage of drivers the pandemic
and construction the bus comes at 10 13
normally
but twice last week
i had to wait the bus didn't show up
until like 5 to 11 or whatever i had to
take an uber home patricia sibo is one
of many who rely on the rtc bus to get
to work she takes the bus four days a
week and just in the last week had to
wait almost an hour i wish they'd hired
more drivers deputy ceo frances julian
says a critical labor shortage almost
everywhere and is working with
contractors to resolve the situation as
quickly as possible and they have added
vehicles to the route a lot of their new
recruits that came from
jobs where they were furloughed or fired
during the pandemic
got recalled and obviously they had more
seniority in their previous jobs some of
the more higher frequency routes
flamingo tropicana charleston sahara and
boulder highway julian added
construction adding major delays to some
routes it takes a month to train a bus
driver
so we're hopeful
and what we're seeing right now with the
campaign
both contractors have a lot of new
recruits that are being trained sibo
says she can wait much longer what's
your solution to this problem for you
buy a car eventually
out here live rtc has put a campaign out
to help recruit drivers in the meantime
they're asking riders to please be
patient use their ride shirt app and
most importantly respect bus drivers
above all sally jaramillo live local now